[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
in this session we're going to build a
web app
together we're going to containerize it
and don't
don't worry if you're not sure what that
means we'll explain it
and we're going to deploy it to the
cloud
um and i think you'll see as we go along
how easy it is and that's one of the
things i love about our
cloud platform my name is mark cohen i'm
a developer advocate
you can find my blog at mco.dev and
on twitter my handle is emco underscore
dev
and let's go to the workshop so i have
one more link for you
g dot co code labs slash dev
to prod so one more time that's g dot
co g dot co slash code labs
c-o-d-e-l-a-b-s slash dev number two
prod d-e-v to p-r-o-d
so if you go there you will see
something that looks a lot like the
window
on the left and this
arrangement you see here is what we're
going to use
for the entire lab what's on the left is
the code lab
that you should see and what's on the
right of the screen
is the cloud console so i'll be able to
kind of go back and forth without
changing windows today
i invite you to set up something similar
to that but whatever you're comfortable
uh is with is fine so let's get into it
um first of all i want to just give you
some background
about application deployment
and the key here to think about is
if you if you have a good application
and you want to deploy it nowadays
there are a ton of different things you
have to worry about like provisioning
hardware installing software
security patching the economics of it
scaling up and down
and so on gets really complex and most
of those
things are really having to do with
infrastructure they don't have to do
with your
your application business logic
and what i really want to concentrate on
when i'm writing an app is just solving
my problem i don't want to do all that
other stuff and so
what i'm going to illustrate for you
today is a way to let google
take care of all the infrastructure for
you so that you don't you can just focus
all your attention on your application
so um let's get set up what we're going
to do is create a project
so you're going to go to the cloud
console that's console.cloud.google
and you're going to create a new project
and you can do that by selecting this
pull down
up the top here and click this
new project button this
will prompt you for a project name a
billing account and in this billing
account pull down
that's where you can select the free
trial account that you just created
if you're using the uh the credits and
then you'll click
create i'm not going to do that right
now because i have a project
i'm going to use that i've already set
up
but that's what you'll want to do if you
don't have a project you
you already want to use if not you can
reuse your project
the next step is we're going to start
the cloud shell
so the cloud shell is this little widget
in the upper right hand uh corner if you
hover over it
it says activate cloud shell so go ahead
and click on that
and you'll get this window or this tab
popping up at the bottom of your screen
saying provisioning your cloud shell
machine let me make this bigger for you
and what this is doing is giving you a
login
and an interactive command processor
on a virtual machine that was allocated
for you so it's all ready to go and you
already have a development
place in the cloud essentially to make
this more visible
i'm going to change my prompt
give me a little more room to
type on the screen here okay so that's
your cloud shell
environment and you're going to probably
have everything
pre-set up the way you want but just in
case you'll want to make sure
that your project is set so you'll run
this command gcloud
config list project and you should see
it displaying the project that you've
just created or that you're reusing and
if you've got that set up
you can also say gcloud off list as
shown here
and that will essentially tell you your
account is set correctly and your author
authenticated rather so you want to do
that as well
and if the project's not set correctly
by the way you can do this command
gcloud config set
gcloud config set project
and then type whatever your project is
but you should be okay with it by
default
i also want you to copy paste
these environment variable settings
this is setting the project number the
project
name in a short variable that we'll use
later the app name the port name
a default region and something called
tag which we'll use when we containerize
your app
last thing on this in this getting setup
stage is we're going to enable
three services that we need to use so
you'll paste those
and by the way when you hit the first uh
command in cloud shell that requires
authorization you'll get this little
pop-up that says authorize cloud shell
go ahead and click
authorize there and we're setting up
cloud
build which will enable us to build our
project in the cloud container registry
to store our container
and the cloud run service so once you've
got those
enabled let's go to the next step which
is
we're going to build our app now this is
going to be a simple app
um but that's fine we want a vehicle
that's not too complicated that we can
use to then see it run locally or at
least running in this
development environment and then we're
going to deploy it to the cloud
so what i want you to do next is click
this open editor button
that i'm hovering over right here and
what that will do
is it will create essentially an
integrated development environment
in the same window so now you'll have a
terminal
an ide and a
m-cloud console what i like to do here
is if you look at this bar
that i'm hovering on you can slide it up
as far as you want and that gives you a
little bit more
screen real estate for
your terminal and shell and you can sort
of go back and forth between the editor
and the terminal sorry i'm using
different terms there
the editor and the terminal i'll try to
use those words consistently
uh you can ping pong back and forth by
clicking these buttons
and then you always have the cloud
console up here you can pull this down
if you need to do more work up there
so i find this to be a convenient setup
for
for getting things done in one combined
window
so let's build our app the first thing
we're going to do is to create a folder
for the app and let's call this folder
hello so we'll
pull down file new folder
enter the the name hello you can
actually call it anything you want but
i'm going to give it that name
here do a little cleanup here
next you're going to want to create a
new file and if you do that it'll put it
in that
folder automatically i think i managed
to put
hello under test which i'm not isn't
going to bother me but you're going to
you'll hopefully get the hello folder
created at the top level
so you're going to do the create new
file
and the name of the file is going to be
requirements.txt
that's a plural requirements.txt
that's under hello which is where we
wanted it to be we're going to
put these two words in there flask and g
unicorn now for for python people
you'll know what this is but if you're
new to this requirements.txt
is a conventional place to put the
required packages for python programs
so once we've done that
we're going to create the first version
of our app
and i'm just going to copy paste this
code under version 1 hello world
i'm going to create a new file
called main.py
i can type it
and we'll paste that code in there let's
take a real quick quick look this is
using the flask
package creating an app getting a port
number from the environment variable we
set earlier
this route is telling it to support this
say hello function for any incoming web
requests
that are directed to the root of the
url or the root path you might call it
and that come in with an http get
request
and all this is going to do this
function is set a variable called html
to this very trivial html document that
says hello world and returns that
which will essentially get it to
percolate out to the to the web browser
so the next thing we're going to do is
go back to the terminal
and you may wonder about why i didn't
have you save it
these files will auto save in the in the
editor so i'm back to the terminal
and as i mentioned earlier i
accidentally put the hello directory
under test
and uh in fact hello is
yes so um
for me i ha i had to just to repeat that
i had to see the test hello
to get to the stuff i wanted for you you
should just see hello and you'll be able
to just say
cd hello so hopefully i'm the only
person
with that um glitch um
now i've got my requirements.txt and
what i want to do
is install the requirements and i'll do
that by saying pip3
install minus r requirements.txt
and that's already finished and next
i'll run my example app so with those
two files i have a very simple web app
i'm going to run it by saying python3
main.pi
and what i can do now is click this web
preview button
if you click there you'll see a preview
on port
8080 and if you do that
it should take you to your app and there
you go you have your
your very uh
sophisticated web app that says hello
world so you can hopefully see that
working for yourself
um we're gonna um tweak the app just a
little bit and i'm gonna actually skip
version two and go to version three
because
um they're just basically adding a
little bit of successive
functionality and i don't think there's
huge value right now
in doing each uh step one at a time so
we're going to kind of jump to the end
of
of this this portion of the lab so what
i'd like you to do is go back to
main.pie
um i'm gonna wipe out what i have there
now when you do this on your own you can
actually
make the changes piece piecemeal because
i've annotated this lab to say
uh you know this line here is new this
line is modified so you can see the
exact changes
but for expedience i'm just going to
select
this whole version three
i'm going to paste it into main.i
and just to give you a sense of what
this is about
i've modified it so that it takes a
portion
of the url and if it exists
meaning if there's something coming
after the slash in the url
it will echo that back instead of world
so if i have slash
google i o it'll say hello google i o
and then the other thing is it's playing
around with the background color
for the the stuff that it presents so
let's go ahead back to the terminal
if you enter control c it should break
out of the existing
app that was running and let's go back
to run python3 again mask
sorry python3 space main dot pi and
we'll do the same thing we did as before
we'll open the
previewer to port 8080 and there we see
the app with a random background color
the other thing i wanted to mention is
as i said earlier you can change the
little
bit after the slash to anything you'd
like
and you get hello google i o so we've
kind of tweaked the app a little bit and
i hope that gives you a sense that
you've got
a pretty uh straightforward
development environment with both the
terminal and an editor
embedded right here into the
cloud console so hopefully you've got
that working
we'll go on to the next step which is to
containerize the app
now i want to take just a minute to
explain what containerizing means
if you imagine taking this app and
sharing it with someone
they would need to make sure they had
all of the things you have in your
environment
and the environment can can encompass a
lot of things right
one way to improve that problem is to
give them your requirements that text
but there's some issues there for
example i didn't specify a particular
version of flask or g unicorn and let's
imagine someone installs this on their
system
and they have a different version of
flask or g unicorn or those packages
change and the most
recent version is it works differently
on top of that the operating system
might have some quirks they might be
using a different version of python
there's all sorts of possible ways that
someone who takes this code could run
into problems and wouldn't it be nice if
we could package up
everything this app needs all of its
dependencies into
one kind of modular bubble
and that's what a container essentially
is it lets you
define everything you need to run this
app anywhere
the way you specify a container is
through something called a docker file
so i want you to create a new file again
called dockerfile with a capital d
you're going to copy this text into
there
and i'll just briefly walk through what
this is doing
[Music]
think of a docker file as a blueprint
for a container so it starts with a from
line which says this is the base
and that's a pre-packaged kind of
foundation for your
container we're going to tell it the
working directory that's where we're
going to do everything it's kind of the
home directory for the container it's
slash
app in this case we're going to copy our
two files paint
main dot py and requirements.txt
we'll install the requirements as we're
building the container
we're going to set the port number and
then here's the command to run
when you start the container and with
that we can build the container
and we're going to do that using the
cloud there are ways to do this locally
using the docker command but i'm going
to switch back to the terminal
control c out of my running python app
and i'm going to do this gcloud builds
submit minus minus tag now the tag is
really just giving the
resulting container image a
a unique name in a namespace so that you
can then refer to the container later
when you want to run it in the cloud or
locally
so this takes a a minute or so
but what's happening here is it's both
building the container and it's pushing
it to a repository so we can refer to it
later
so now we have the container built we
can say
gcloud container images list if we want
to actually see all the containers we've
built
and here's the one i just made gcr dot
io that's the container repository
a registry i think mco cloud run
is my project and hello is the the app
so that container has the app in it and
it's ready to run
now before i go to the cloud let's just
run that container locally which we can
do
and just test that the container
works exactly like the app did when i
ran it with python main dot
py python 3 main dot py i'm giving a
couple arguments for something called
port mapping and that's to map the port
from the host system from my macbook
into the internal port
in the containers kind of view of the
world
and i end the command with dollar tag
and again that's how i tell docker
that's the image that i want you to run
it said unable to find image because it
didn't see a copy of it locally so it
pulled it from the container registry
and now it should be running
although i was expecting to see a little
bit more
let's go ahead and see if it's running
and
yeah it is running so um
you can see that it's uh it's looking
exactly like it was when i ran it
locally and just to prove it's actually
running i'm going to
cancel out of it go back here
and refresh the screen and you see i got
couldn't connect to server on port 8080.
so just to review what we've done we
built an app we
ran it locally and then we containerized
it and by doing so we now have this
module i can give to anyone and be
confident
that app is going to run exactly for
them the same way it did for me
which is super powerful
okay um now what do we want to do next
imagine we built this app it's a great
app and we want to share it with the
world
well we don't want to give people
the container and tell them to run a
container we want to just deploy it on
the web and have people be able to visit
a website and and experience the app so
we really want to send this app
or deploy it in the cloud
now um one of the great things about
the product i'm going to be using to
deploy it which is called cloud run
is that it's going to give you all of
that administrative stuff that i talked
about at the beginning
all of that infrastructure it's going to
give you that for free
it's going to give you very good
reliability and availability it's going
to scale
automatically it's going to minimize
your cost because you're only going to
pay for when the app is actually running
it's going to give you the ability to in
one easy step to add a custom domain
name
it's going to give you security with
standard
ssl tls https type
encryption and as you're gonna see it
gives you very good response time
so how do we do that well let's go back
to the cloud editor
let's go to our main dot pi file and
where it says name equals world instead
of world we're going to say from
[Music]
cloud run so when we run this on cloud
run we should see a slightly different
message hello from cloud run
now that we've made that very small
source change let's go ahead
and run it now this
lab says to do a build submit but we've
already done that so we actually can
skip that step and we should be able to
just run this command so let's go back
to the terminal
let me bring this up here
and we're going to run the deploy
command now what this deploy is saying
is my name is
but the name of my app is hello that's
the dollar app variable that we set
the image i want you to use is dollar
tag we've set that as well and been
using that when we build
i want the managed platform which is
there's another way you can use cloud
run where you have
you can sort of use your own uh cloud
you can you can sort of use your own
lower level infrastructure but we're
going to use the higher abstraction
level
and request this managed platform you
can specify the region and allow
unauthenticated this part right here is
basically saying i want anybody to be
able to access this website they don't
need to log in
and you can see i talked a lot longer
than it took for it to deploy this app
it's actually all ready to go
now we can't just do the the local um
preview here because it's actually been
assigned a global
globally accessible url but we can just
click on this
url to see it and there's our app once
again but now it's running in the cloud
so if we send a lot of traffic to it and
we will later
we can see that it'll automatically
scale to to meet the
offered demand that's how easy it was to
take an app that was in development
to containerize it and to run it on the
cloud
now um as easy as that was i still had
to think about
this notion of a docker file and and i
had to come up with that
that blueprint in order to figure out
um you know how to
how to build the the container image
wouldn't it be nice if i didn't have to
have to do that and that's exactly what
i'm going to show you how to do using
something called build packs
so i want you to go back to the editor
again and we're going to once again
change the the message oh i forgot to
point out
earlier that the message said from cloud
run which showed us we were actually
getting that version of the app
but now we're going to change it from
saying from cloud run to saying from
cloud run with build packs
and in order to use build packs we have
to add one more
file so under hello we're going to say
new file
and we're going to create a file called
proc file p-r-o-c-f-i-l-e with a capital
p
go ahead and create that now and all
that has to be in this file
is this one line web telling it's
it's a web app python 3 is the
environment
and uh starting uh starting up the app
will this is really giving it the
equivalent of how do i start the
container
and it's simply python3 main.py which
we've been using all along
now with this uh one line and a slightly
different deployment command
i'm going to get the system to build the
docker file
and and create the image for me without
me having to work out what the docker
file should look like
so what i'm going to do is actually
delete this file
now the docker file is gone and if i go
back to the terminal
and do an ls you can see there's my proc
file
but there's no longer a docker file and
so now i'm going to build the same
service and let the system figure out
how to make the container for me now
this is going to take a little bit
longer because it has to do a build but
let me just explain what's different
instead of giving an image with a tag i
didn't have to do that you'll notice
there's no
dollar tag appearing in this command but
there's this new argument
dash dash source dot and dot in linux
and unix derived systems
is a shorthand for the current directory
so this is telling gcloud
all of a source for my app lives right
in this directory
and i didn't give you a tag but i put a
proc file on there to tell you the
minimum i need to tell you
create the container for me build it
deposit it in the container repository
and deploy it
all in one command and now i've gotten
to the point where
i don't even have to think about a
docker file what it is
how to code it um i can just again
create my app and deploy it to the cloud
it just makes everything easier for me
as a developer
as i said this takes a bit longer so
what i might do is
jump ahead to the next step of the lab
and we'll keep an eye on this window in
the meantime
so um
do you have to use the command line
obviously i'm doing everything in this
lab via the command line
and i i'm gonna just increase the size
here so it's a little easier to see
and uh the short answer is no you don't
have to use the command line
i used it in this lab because it's it's
easy to show and it's easy to reproduce
and copy things but
um there's three different ways to use
the
google cloud one is through the command
line that we've seen a lot of another is
through the
the web interface which is you know up
here at the top of the screen and the
last is programmatically so
you can use any of a number of supported
client libraries as well so with that in
mind i do just want to show you quickly
what the web portion looks like
by the way this finished building
i think yes and it's now deploying and
it's done so we get another
url here and it's not going to look too
much different
except that now it says with build packs
so this is telling us it got our new
version
and so we were able to deploy this
version
without even thinking about a docker
file straight to the cloud with all
these nice benefits
so what i wanted to show you here is
um what the web version of all this
looks like
so you have this project up here and you
can go to with the with the
navigation menu on the upper left you
can go to the cloud run
page and you'll see all of your services
so here's the one i just deployed it's
called hello
and if you go to the revisions tag
you can see the four versions that i've
deployed the last one
is hello 004 diy and that's getting 100
of the traffic you can see your url here
you can get details about the uh the
deployment
somewhere in here i can get the
specifics about the
um i think if i click over here
here it is the image url is shown over
here so that's the
exact container image that we built and
stored in the
in the registry and we can say manage
traffic
to actually point a different percentage
of the incoming traffic at
different levels of or different
revisions of our service
and that's really handy if you're
wanting to canary like where you have a
new revision and you just want a small
percentage of your traffic going there
to make sure things are okay before you
deploy it more widely
it's also quite handy for a b testing
so um yeah there's a lot of things you
can do
here i didn't even show that you can
just create a brand new service from
scratch
um you can give it give it a name
you'll give it the container image you
can set some advanced
settings uh kind of configuring various
things like the hardware how you want
the auto scaling to work you can specify
a minimum
number of instances and so on so
lots of stuff you can do pretty much
everything you can do
that i showed you from the command line
you can do from the
console as well which is great and you
can also do the all that good stuff with
uh
with client libraries programmatically
so i'll let you read through this later
when you do the lab on your own
if you come back to it um
before i have you clean up your work
we're going to test the app so i want
you to go back
to the
editor slash terminal window we'll slide
that up
and we'll go to actually i'm at the
terminal if you're in the editor click
the open terminal button to go back
there
let me make this bigger
and clear the screen at the top
now the cloud shell comes with a bunch
of nice capabilities built right in for
example
there's a there's a well the gcloud
command
for example came automatically installed
and i'm going to use a load test tool
called hey
you can see what that does for yourself
but what we're going to use it for
is to run some traffic against the
service that i just deployed
so here's the command i'm going to use
i'll paste it in here now
um minus q option is telling it how many
requests per second so i'm going to
drive this traffic at a thousand
requests per second
minus c is how many parallel workers i
want so we'll have
200 parallels not really threads they're
go routines
because this program was written in the
go language
and the minus z tells how many
um how long to run for i'm going to
actually change that to 15 seconds so
we're not waiting too long
and the last thing i'm going to do is
change the url
now if we go back to
our cloud run service we can pick the
url from right here click that button
we'll copy it to the clipboard
and then i'll just paste it
i i am unable to
access this window
so these things happen i'm going to
reload the browser and see if i can make
my way back
this page is dead is officially dead so
let's see if i can resurrect it in a new
tab
and if it doesn't work i'm just going to
move on but let's give it
give it one shot
okay so here's my um
url and
let's go back to home
let's make this smaller
so my cloud shell is not
there it is okay
let's move this up
oops
nicer prompt clear the screen here's my
url
and now we're going to whoops let's
turn on
brand editing here's the url
and let's turn on um or rather let's do
this command
so what we want is hey through the rest
of the options
and there we finally have the command i
wanted to run except i said i wanted to
do it for uh
15 seconds so i just broke out of it so
i can do it for
less time i'll change this 30 to 15
and let's set let's let that kind of
percolate
[Music]
what it's going to do is basically
hammer on the
service i just deployed and it's going
to gather statistics
so let's review what it's telling us
the the total amount of data was almost
a megabyte
uh it it lasted for a little over 15
seconds as i specified
the slowest entirely slowest response
time was
uh three quarters of a second the
fastest
was 186 milliseconds on average it was
287 milliseconds
the request per second was um
almost 700 per second which is not too
bad i'd ask for a thousand per second
but for various reasons
primarily related to the hardware i'm
running on right now
i didn't quite get there but that's not
too bad um
it shows a histogram a nice response
time
uh distribution to show you that
most of the responses where we had one
kind of uh
outlier here most response responses
were fairly well behaved at the low end
of the scale
and the 95th percentile for example
was
567 milliseconds
i'll run that one more time and the key
idea here that i want to point out
is that if you send a lot of traffic
cloud run is just going to automatically
expand the number of reasons the amount
of resources it's providing
in order to enable you to keep up with
the demand
so it will grow and it will shrink based
on the traffic
and this goes back to my original
comment we're doing this
the infrastructure work for you you
don't have to worry about
allocating resources it'll just
magically happen for you so you can
focus on writing your application
this one pretty similar results so um
yeah the other thing i wanted to mention
is back on the
um cloud console
there is a metrics page where you can
view the
i i won't go there now but you can view
the servers that
the google cloud cloud run version or
or perspective of all of the statistics
you
you get graphics about response time um
latency requests per second
errors all kinds of useful information
so you can compare the client side with
the server side and get some
some good feedback there so that's
really
uh what i wanted you to do with me today
the last thing i want you
to be aware of is that when you do an
experiment like this you should always
clean up after yourself so that you
don't accumulate
charges after the fact so what you can
do
is run gcloud container images delete
dollar tag and what that will do
is remove your
container that you just created
from the cloud registry that you stored
now that didn't work
and the reason is if you remember i ran
into a problem and i had to restart
cloud shell
and i lost those environment settings
that it did right at the beginning
so if that happens to you if you have to
restart or reload the window
in the middle of this lab you might find
things working a little bit erratically
and so
or not working at all and so in that
case you'll want to go back and reset
these helper variables and now i think
if i go back and do the
deletion command i can just recall it
here
now it's got dollar tag and it's saying
are you sure you really want to delete
that and i'll say yes
and the last thing is um i won't do this
but you can
uh delete the the services
as well the cloud run services that you
deployed and then when you look at them
on the cloud console you'll see
they're gone so that's really the lab
um i just wanted to to summarize what
you've learned
you have built a very simple web app
admittedly
but you've containerized it you've
deployed it to production
as we went through this you hopefully
learned a little bit about containers
and how to build your own container
you saw that it's nice to know about
containers but you actually didn't even
need
to know the details in order to
you know to build a container thanks to
the build packs feature
and then you saw how easy it is to
deploy this service
using both the gcloud command line tool
and the console
so now your your application can be
served
with real confidence to anyone in the
world
with all these great features and the
one question i want to leave you with is
now that you've got your app working in
production
how many lines of code did we have to
change to modify it
from the starting version to the
deployed version and the answer
and it's it's one of my favorite things
the answer is zero
okay i did change the little hello tag
to save from
run or from cloud run with build packs
but that was cosmetic the rest of the
code
i literally did not have to touch and to
me like going from one environment to
another
more advanced more sophisticated
environment
without having to think about what that
impact is going to be on my code
is a great thing and that's one of the
reasons i love using cloud run
there's some resources here for you to
do more
more reading um i i will just remind you
of the link to the code lab it's g dot
co
slash code labs slash dev to
prod and
i'm probably finishing a little bit
early but hopefully that was
helpful to you and if i can help you
with anything feel free to reach out to
me again it's emco.dev
on twitter emco underscore dev and to
find out more about cloud run go to
cloud.google.com
run and with that i will thank you for
your attention
and i hope you learned something and had
a good time
you